okay it is now time for hatred mail
we've got a very special hatred mail
this week but first a reminder what is
hatred mail anyway it's like taking an
apple pie filling it with pages from the
Old Testament topping it with hollow
points and serving it with a side of
homophobia Patriot mail written by
Patriots who hate David Pakman because
America and because freedom side of
homophobia you heard during that
introduction that is relevant to this
week's hatred mail David Pakman and the
other guy on the show are both gay
together this was a pointless back video
Pakman guy doesn't know a damn thing
about what he's talking about
how long before Pakman loses all his
credibility I heard from someone that
David Pakman likes to Ducks must be true
so layer one is oh well David is clearly
gay and that's an insult
and the quote other guy hat is clearly
gay and that's an insult but layer two
is they are gay together I'm pretty sure
this is the first time that I've been
mentioned in a hatred mail really and
I'm only referred to as the other guy so
I guess that takes time
don't worry I wouldn't be too anxious to
be mentioned more specifically in
Hadrian mail
have you heard this story of there was a
non homophobic story related to lewis
and i being quote gay together even
though we both date women hurt which is
that i got an email from someone saying
david I love the program I think what
you and Lewis are doing is terrific
independent media blah blah blah and
it's also so great that you're working
with your significant other on the
program and my husband and I would like
to invite you guys out to dinner sort of
as a double date in Boston they just
went boom because you have great
chemistry together they're gonna be
romantic with each other I don't know
what it was but in any case I thought
well what if I didn't tell Louis what
the pretext was and I said sure yeah
we'll go and then I brought Louis to the
and let it sort of be revealed by
context that the other couple thought it
was a double-date
but we weren't even living in Boston at
the time and it would have been sort of
a weird yeah to do so I said you know
I'm thrilled by the way Lewis and I
happen to not be together we also both
exclusively date women but I really
appreciate the support yeah that's the
thing I mean this hate reott not only
assumes that we are gay but also that we
must be dating we must yeah like maybe
you're not my type that's absolutely
possible that is absolutely possible
turn hatred mail into something positive
you can use the coupon hook code
Patriots for tha t RI ot for zero to get
a 40% discount off of membership at
david pakman.com slash membership